[Music]
pftot monday edition the place where we
talk about some things we didn't get to
during pft live or just some other stuff
we feel like rehashing and let's take a
look chris at what some of the higher
profile teams in the nfl accomplished in
the draft and it may be that
jerry jones the owner of the cowboys
will want to do all of his drafts from
his yacht moving forward the yacht
apparently is good luck because the
combination of the the soothing
motion of the ocean or wherever he has
that damn thing parked plus being away
from all the frenetic activity of the
draft room apparently it combined to
give the cowboys a pretty good showing
at least based upon what we know
and and the caveat my caveat that we
don't know what any of these guys are
going to do until they get there what
we've seen so far from the cowboys it's
promising by way of bumping up the
talent on the roster definitely well you
know they always say it's not the size
of the boat it's the motion of the ocean
mike florio okay and he does have a big
boat and apparently it's a nice motion
of the ocean too but they killed it i
mean i had some fun with that okay you
left it out there just dangled it for me
i couldn't help it that's true all right
yes yes i did
um but you know i do think they're a
team that's certainly worthy of us
putting in the upper class of teams that
killed it in the draft i mean when you
get cd lamb
viewed by most of the most talented
receiver in the draft then in the second
round to get a corner and and tab and uh
trayvon diggs stefan digg's little
brother who a lot of people looked at as
a end of the first round type talent as
well phenomenal ball skills well coach
they got a need there because byron
jones left town so now you got another
starter to replace him basically right
away they didn't have to try to put one
of their nickel guys outside and try to
make that happen and then mike their
third round pit
neville gallimore the kid from oklahoma
you know and again like you've always
said it's a crap shoot we'll see where
this goes but he was one of my favorite
interior d linemen in the draft he has
some serious f to play up potential he
was the best interior pass rusher in the
draft i thought other than derrick brown
and i i think there's some real value to
what the cowboys did in this job they're
going to get people that are going to
contribute right away
from the start of the season
yeah i mean the cd lamp thing was so
significant because i still feel like 22
years later jerry jones is trying to
atone for not taking randy moss as he
slid in the first round of the draft
remember moss was under the impression
that the cowboys were going to take him
if he was on the board they didn't cd
lamb is sitting there at 17 and it
almost makes that offense potentially
unfair when you consider the offensive
line still one of the better ones in the
nfl ezekiel dak press got to marry
cooper and you throw cd lamb into the
mix uh they could be a dynamic offensive
team in mike mccarthy's first year as
the head coach and uh they i'm surprised
you didn't mention a couple of guys
tyler and i it looks like you could
pronounce his last name badass i'm just
gonna call him tyler badass
b-i-a-d-a-s-z but he comes in at the
center position and i know it's it's not
given where he's drafted on saturday
an automatic that he plugs right in for
travis frederick but they needed to
address that position i'm surprised they
waited as long as they did chris
no well you you know they they got a
good eye for talent that that's what we
do know and then if you're looking for
good offensive line play wisconsin's
always a good play to always get a good
place to look so not that they're
desperate at the center position
they got guys there that i think that
they think can fill in right away even
without this rookie but now this gives
them a little bit more depth and
flexibility there if there is an injury
to happen or anything like that and even
mike the guy they got in this the fifth
round with pick 34 in the fifth round
bradley and
a from utah you know this is what i like
about dallas later in the draft they
take chances on guys that they saw
a few elite things from an a from utah
is a really gifted talented pass rusher
now he's a little underwhelming in the
other parts of his game he's not great
at defending the run but i think they're
going to find a role for this kid where
on third downs he'll be a pain in the
butt coming off the edge he's slippery
knows how to use his hands there's a lot
of different weapons as far as pass rush
moves are concerned so you know i i
really applaud the jones family they
have quite an eye for talent and uh i
think they plugged a lot of holes and
improved their football team this
weekend
yeah you know and again we'll see how
these guys pan out but they had lost so
many guys in free agency we've been so
focused on the dak prescott contract and
amari cooper who they kept um
a lot of gaps that needed to be filled
and they worked toward doing that all
right by the way it's tyler be a dish i
prefer tyler badass for the new
cowboy center and they're gonna need him
to be a badass all right the kansas city
chiefs are the baddest of the badasses
in the nfl right now the defending super
bowl champions we have had much to say
about clyde edwards hillaire the lsu
running back who was the 32nd overall
pick in the draft your top running back
in the draft the chiefs apparently
agreed what did you think of the rest of
their selections chris
well i you know again getting an
offensive lineman right in round three
and lucas niang or nayang you know you
watch him he's a giant human being
and andy reed's one of those guys where
you know like we talk about with other
teams like the steelers with the
receiver when andy reid drafts an
offensive lineman i always like perk up
because i think he's a little bit of an
offensive lineman whisperer he's got a
very keen eye for finding finding guys
in the mid rounds of the draft and then
two or three years from now we turn
around and we go damn this guy's a good
player and oh man andy found himself a
hidden gem once again he's very good at
that but then in round two you know
linebacker position a little bit of need
as far as the kansas city chiefs are
concerned they get willy gay junior the
kid from mississippi state who's really
athletic can fly around the field almost
like a
athletic strong safety with the way he
moves so i think there was a great value
in those two picks i look at the top
three picks and go there's again they
got two two picks and the linebacker and
the running back they're gonna
contribute right away with an offensive
lineman then again just gives them a
little bit more depth and somebody for
the future to take over when they do
lose some guys so i i you know i'm a big
fan of brett beach and andy reid they
always seem to have uh a a plan of
attack as far as what they want to do
with their team
yeah and look
they get the benefit of the doubt right
now because they have put together
one of the best rosters in the nfl and
any guy that brett veach takes i'm
giving him the benefit of the doubt
because he's the guy that found patrick
mahomes one of the greatest players in
nfl history after only three nfl
seasons the greatest quarterback of all
time in the opinion of some tom brady
gone from the new england patriots we
talked during the show today about the
fact that the patriots did not draft any
quarterbacks because as bill belichick
said it wasn't part of the design it was
just the way things played out and the
way it played out they had plenty of
picks traded out of round one which they
have done in the past what did you make
of the entire
a collection of draft picks that the
patriots put together this year chris
well they lost jamie collins and kyle
van noy right in in free agency dante
hightower's getting up there in age we
know they value those hybrid type
linebackers who could do a lot of
different things so you look in the
second and third round they get josh
ushay from michigan who's like a outside
linebacker inside linebacker defense to
end athletic freak hybrid so that
certainly makes sense pick three and for
dean jennings from alabama another guy
that's kind of an outside linebacker
defensive end hybrid so they're going to
be able to use him in a lot of different
ways and then really pick number five
around two kyle duggar from lenoir-rhyne
mike you know this is the number four
safety on my you know big board at that
position
he's got some superstar like
if he hits he could be like a sean
taylor type of a talent i mean that's
really what he is mike the only thing
that scares you is just the competition
in which he played but i think this you
know again the patriots between here we
go let's not forget they were a
defensive football team last year they
won
almost all their games because of their
defense and i think bill belichick is
showing you again he plans on playing
that type of style and then mike also
got asia c the tight end right from ucla
in the third round
you could argue him or cole comet were
the two most talented tight ends in the
draft i think there were some off the
field questions with asia c but big time
talent mike and a nice friendly target
for jared simon down the middle of the
field so the the patriots killed it as
they usually do you know they're smart
with what they do and their approach is
always
a couple of third round tight ends a csc
and dalton keene uh just 10 picks apart
no receivers plenty of offensive linemen
late in the process a kicker
uh which they need now that stephen
gaskowski has moved on and anytime
anytime you draft a kicker um
it makes people nervous because you can
find so many of those guys after the
draft has ended you better believe in
justin rohrwasser as a fifth round pick
or uh you end up
squandering that selection that could
have been devoted to something else but
again belichick gets the benefit of the
doubt because of the six rings the pelts
on the wall and or the pellets on the
horse and uh the very spartan no frills
draft setup that he had uh with his dog
and with his two computers it's
belichick he's
he probably could have done it all with
a telephone he probably didn't even need
a computer there he had a he could have
had a binder and an old phone the one
they used to put on the wall in the
kitchen with the long cord that's all he
would have needed and he would have well
done well mike you're exactly right too
and you know there is something to that
you know he had two computers there
right it looked like he had one that was
a mac and one that was a pc
and most organizations you run pcs
because they have certain formats and
things like that where you can you know
have your your evaluations of guys set
up in certain ways and it's good that
way but i thought i thought this was
interesting to me too
you know most of these guys that you saw
with these setups and these screens
everywhere right one of the things a lot
of these gm's and talent evaluators do
during the draft is when they get into
the middle to late rounds
they sit there and go back and watch
film to go oh i know which one do i like
more do i like this guy more and they
have a conversation with it on the fly
during the draft new england's
they're like no no we we've evaluated
these guys so exhaustedly we don't need
to go back and look we know exactly what
we're doing we've we've evaluated these
guys for three years and we've looked
under every rock and know everything
about their family history to where they
don't need to do like oh last second oh
it was close between this guy or that
guy let's evaluate them one more time
and we'll make our pick no they're
they're ready to go and they don't need
that type of setup so i i kind of found
that intriguing too
yeah i talked about it i talked about
this with someone over the weekend the
idea that that there's a point where you
just have to do it you cannot allow
yourself
to continue to talk and talk and talk
and think you'll talk yourself out of a
guy that you're sold on you talk
yourself into a guy that you shouldn't
be sold on you just need to have the
conviction that you you spent all that
time putting your board together you
made those decisions then do not go back
and revisit those decisions now it just
clutters your mind you need to have a
streamlined process i mean here's the
example i can give you like during free
agency i've tried this in the past where
i'll try to bring in like a different
laptop and just have even more screens
going so i don't miss anything and it's
just more distraction right you know
your process you know how you get your
information you know what you believe
you know how you do things why do you
want to make it more complicated and put
more things in front of your eyes and in
your brain that potentially going to
screw you up and i think bill belichick
has proven to everyone you just you you
have to trust what you've done and keep
it simple uh so you can make the picks
as quick as you need to the rams needed
picks this year chris they needed them
badly after all the guys that we saw
depart this offseason from todd gurley
being cut to brandon cooks being traded
it's just this general sense that the
rams have slid into a a pool of
dysfunction not long after making it to
the super bowl what did you think of
what they did with their draft picks
well i like their draft i did for a team
that didn't have a first round pick i
thought they made the most of what what
was available to them cam acres from
florida state i think to be the todd
gurley replacement to nonetheless split
time with the running back they took
from memphis last year in henderson so
that makes a lot of sense and acres is
really talented you know i think a lot
of people looked at him as one of the
five best running backs in the draft
mike i honestly thought he was every bit
as good as deandre swift from georgia i
mean i made deandre swift number five
only because i saw a little bit more in
the past game but i'm not so sure i
wasn't more impressed with what i saw
running the football and how it
translates to the nfl and cam makers but
that then to get van jefferson mike van
jefferson like
probably the best route running wide
receiver in the draft even better than
the jerry judy's and the justin
jeffersons really well schooled his dad
an ex-nfl receiver and coach you know as
a coach for the new york jets right now
he can be a lot like a cooper cup that
they already have there so there's
another weapon to go along with robert
woods is going to be able to do things
and then mike my favorite terrell lewis
in round three
this this other than clayvon chason and
chase young this was the third best pass
rusher in the draft now he had injury
history at alabama but if he's healthy
his talent is top 20 pick in the draft
type talent he's had some knee issues he
played all his games last year he missed
i think a little bit here and there but
nonetheless was pretty much healthy he's
special and then you talk about what
they did in free agency with a sean
robinson and leonard floyd and got
michael brockers back the one thing i'll
say is their defense is going to be a
real pain in the butt i know that
they've got some studs over there
watch out for the nfc west those four
teams all holy cow series contenders
this year including the cardinals
including the cardinals who got isaiah
simmons with that eighth overall pick
and that offense continues to get better
and better and uh they're going to be a
factor as well all right before we go we
didn't talk about this during the show
today there wasn't time for it but the
bill o'brien decision to give laramie
tunsil 22 million per year on just i
think a three-year extension is it a
three-year deal beyond the one year he
had left not a whole lot of a commitment
there from the player a lot of money
from the team what were your thoughts on
the extension that laramie tunsil signed
with the houston texans chris well i
mean laramie tunzel's got the houston
texans and bill o'brien over the
wheelbarrow i mean that's what he's got
he's got him right where he wanted you
know and this is why i think we had us
we saw that houston texas trade away
de'andre hopkins they knew they were
going to be paying top market type money
to laramie tunzel and then as we all
know deshaun watson is on the horizon as
well but
i mean
bill o'brien and the texans they they
you know they did this to themselves
they negotiated themselves in the corner
with this one with the way and assets
they traded away from laramie tunsil
it's my understanding mike i mean
laramie tunsil knew he had the texans
over the wheelbarrow to such a point
that he he didn't even have an agent do
this deal he saved his three percent
because he knew he got him he didn't
need an agent to go i want to be the
highest paid tackle and i want a
three-year deal or i leave town and all
those first picks you traded away from
me are out the door so uh he's a really
good football player he is one of the
top three four five best pass protectors
in football is he the best left tackle
in football no i would say not but as we
see with other positions when it's your
time to sign and you're in that
conversation you usually become the
highest paid guy
and you know how i feel about this a
good agent would have gotten
enough more beyond what tunzel got on
his own to justify the three percent and
i agree with that there was there was
talk that he was going to move on from
his agent i'm i'm looking to see now uh
i'm pretty sure he did i had heard from
some people in the nfl world that he had
moved on from his agent if i if i am
wrong i i stand corrected but i'm in the
process i'm in the process of checking
while we speak but look this is what
happens when you do that trade without
insisting that the deal is done the
moment you do the trade the rams screwed
this up the same way with jalen ramsey
last year it's one of the impediments to
a yannick and gawkway trade you're not
going to trade for a franchise tagged
pass rusher and not have him signed to a
new deal so what mike i think the big
thing
yeah
you have to do it if you do that kind of
trade you have to do the deal on the way
through the door no doubt about it i
mean you know i think about jalen ramsey
with the rams right now and he should he
should just do the same thing you know
just
absolutely blow the deal out of the
market you know
that's to me i think the biggest [ __ ] uh
shocking thing here mike you know it's
not like he just one-upped lane johnson
as being the highest paid tackle in
football he upped him by four million
dollars i mean that that's insane i mean
that's like you know again that that to
me is a huge market jump right there for
a player you know with laramie tunzel
who i said again is really good uh but
man 22 million as compared to the next
guy in line is 18 million and anthony
costanzo at 16.5 million i mean that's
above market price i'm always for the
players getting money you know that but
man this is a very expensive uh ordeal
for for the use of texans
and there's a certain kind of justice in
all of this for tunsil how he had his
draft stock tumble four years ago during
the first round because some jerk
hacked into his social media and put
that gas mask bong video out there that
made people shy away from him at a time
when he was going to make a lot more
under his rookie deal because he would
have been taken a lot higher than i
think 13th by the dolphins so to get
that money on the back end good for
larry mutunsel because i think he got
screwed four years ago it's nice to see
him uh get uh get the better of the
screwing this time around
yeah no i agreed you're right he did he
got screwed over and you know what you
know it was by somebody close to him too
and it's certainly laramie tunzel was
going to be a top five pick that year so
you're right that takes the edge off of
that and uh hopefully uh makes up for
the the difference he lost in his bank
account
all right so uh that's it for pftot tell
us what you have going on later today
with unbuttoned chris well we're gonna
do a full draft recap that's what we're
gonna do monday afternoon me and ahmed
fareed we'll break it down the teams
that we thought killed it throughout the
draft address some other teams that we
think might have stunk it up or whatever
it may be but it will be a fully draft
centric podcast on kristin's unbutton
this afternoon mike
and you know what now that you mentioned
ahmed because he's doing the background
battles i think you need to invade that
segment at some point and critique his
background with the barry sanders jersey
hanging over his shoulder i i think that
his it's fair game he's opened the door
the door swings
agreed i i don't trust me i'll get him
don't worry we'll we'll get there all
right we look forward to that we'll look
forward to unbutton later today we look
forward to doing pft live again tomorrow
and i look forward to seeing the numbers
go up all day long as you check out
profootballtalk.com
in real time throughout the course of
the day plenty of draft reaction plenty
of information rumors analysis
transactions etc we'll see you there and
we'll see you back here again tomorrow
have a great
[Music]
day hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports